demain à la courneuve a lieu le grand
concert chanteur sans frontières de 14h
à 20h avec une foultitude de chanteurs
français également des africains et cela
vous le savez pour aider l'ethiopie
frappées par la famine
alors après le disque qui a rapporté 10
millions de francs on espère que le
concert aura une recette au moins
équivalent pierre bachelet participent à
cette manifestation est avec nous ce
soir
alors pierre comment ça se présente a la
courneuve ça se présente bien beaucoup
de répétitions tout le monde est là tout
le monde essaie d'être très exact parce
que bon jeu d'accès quand même une
entreprise de grande envergure on a une
soixantaine de chanteurs louis plus de
60 et tout le monde est présent donc
évidemment c'est toujours un peu
bousculé parce que ce genre de
manifestation est difficile d'organiser
mais je crois que tout le monde y met
pleins de bonne volonté et que ça
devrait se passer très très bien alors
on a dit que l'objectif était de
récolter au moins 10 millions de francs
comme le disque est ce que c'est pas un
peu risqué non de le site de donner
d'abord un chiffre oui vous savez je
peux toujours dire que on essaye de
récupérer plus possible je crois que
c'est ça qu'il faut dire aimer ce qu'on
récupérera sera sera bien je pense que
on attend on attend beaucoup de monde et
je pense que le temps est un peu avec
nous
on riait que le plateau je pensais quand
même assez exceptionnel on n'a pas vu ça
en france on n'a jamais vu ça en france
je crois je pense que les gens ont vite
venir est donc on aura un maximum de
recettes
alors on lit ici et là dans la presse
que le concert a failli être annulée
parce que certains trouvaient qu'il
avait été trop hâtivement organisée
voyez vous savez quand on commence à
organiser quelque chose évidemment c'est
difficile de mettre tout le monde
d'accord alors c'est vrai qu' on aurait
pu en effet attendre peut-être le mois
de mai comme certains l'ont dit et pour
faire quelque chose de très organisé où
on aurait pu encore rassemblé beaucoup
plus monde où on aurait pu encore faire
des choses de plus grande des sorts je
crois que l'important c'était de faire
dans le feu de l'action
c'était de le faire quand les gens
avaient tous envie de le faire quand
nous avions tous envie de le faire
pendant que le public était encore
mobilisé par ce disque où il a répondu
d'une façon massive présent puisque le
disque s'est énormément de tendue et je
pense qu'il est bien de le faire dans
cette spontanéité
alors évidemment on peut toujours dire
que avec plus de temps plus
d'organisation etc les choses auraient
pu être encore plus grandiose je veux
dire on le fait avec tout notre coeur je
pense tous les gens qui le king lui qui
participe le fond et tout leur coeur et
je pense que ça ça remplace l'impression
si c'est que les français courent un peu
les chanteurs français qui ont un peu
derrière leurs collègues anglo-saxons
parce qu'en fin de compte le moteur a
été donnée par bob geldof par les
anglais les américains nous on arrive
après avec notre concert peu moins
important oui c'est vrai je voudrais pas
être méchant je devrais pas dire que
c'est souvent comme ça il n'y a pas que
pour l'été au pic c'est comme ça c'est
souvent en tout cas en musique c'est
vrai qu'on arrive assez souvent derrière
les anglo saxons et con mais je crois
que j'avais l'important c'est de le
faire alors que ce soit après que ce
soit un peu moins grand que ce soit pas
télévisée en direct que ce soit pas ceci
que ce soit pas cela on le fait et c'est
ça le principal oui alors dans ce genre
de problème il ya peut être un
inconvénient
bon vous vous mobilisez vous ramasser de
l'argent pour l'ethiopie pour la famine
dans le monde
alors est-ce que vous ne donnez pas
bonne conscience au gouvernement au
pluriel des pays occidentaux qui en
principe doivent aussi aider le pays
pays du tiers-monde assuré non je crois
que aussi si on donne bonne conscience
gouvernement c'est une si mauvaise
tactique mais je ne pense pas je pense
que ça n'a rien à voir je pense que ce
que nous faisons
si vous voulez c'est bon d'abord de
recueillir de l'argent mais en plus de
sensibiliser vraiment l'opinion et je
crois qu'elle a déjà été sensibilisés
avec la chanson avec les chansons
puisque chaque pays a fait une chanson
et que chaque pays a fait un tube avec
cette chanson je crois que l'opinion a
été sensibilisé il faut continuer à
sensibiliser je pense que les
gouvernements seront eux mêmes obligés
de deux peut-être au contraire d'aller
au delà je crois je ne pense pas qu'ils
pourront 0 contre à bas puisque les
chanteurs font leur fond de notre boulot
laissons-les faire je ne pense pas ça et
puis de toute façon je pense que
l'opinion publique et c'est très
important c'était là prêt qui qui
demande qui demande qu'on fasse plus et
qui demande bon alors on a fait ça mais
alors maintenant qu'est ce qu'on va
faire
oui par parenthèse vous parliez du
disque vous ne participiez pas ce disque
dont j'ai pas participer à ce disque
croire que parce que je n'ai pas eu
connaissance de son projet et unis de
son existence que je laisse eu après et
que j'en étais d'ailleurs un peu peiné
un peu peiné mais je pense que c'est
quand on fait les choses avec
précipitation comme on fait ce concert
il ya toujours quelques oublis et là il
y en a eu dans le disque je crois que là
pour ce qu'on sait en tout cas on est
pratiquement tout cela je crois que tout
le monde a répondu présent je crois que
tout le monde a été contacté 3 c'est ça
le principe j'ai vu aussi qu'un certain
nombre de chanteurs étaient assez
méfiant et voulait vraiment que le le
produit de la recette soit strictement
contrôlés et que l'on sache exactement
où va l'argent
oui c'est à dire que là vous avez encore
chacun a son caractère chacun à son vous
avez des gens qui font se conservent
tous très spontanément et puis qui
demande qui ne demandent pas plus et
vous avez d'autres gens qui ont envie
d'être un peu plus responsables qui
disent voilà moi j'en gendre quelque
chose que je fais partie d'une
organisation qui engendre quelque chose
qui va recueillir de l'argent et je suis
quelque part responsable de cet argent
qui va se balader un petit peu partout
alors donc je veux savoir où va-t-il
aller est-ce qu'il va bien y aller eux
d'où partent il est que représente-t-il
au départ que représente-t-il à
l'arrivée ce qui me semble tout à fait
normal je pense que c'est pour obliger
si vous voulez les associations
kiki qui sont à côté de nous et qu'il y
ait un tiers arrêtera amener un peu de
précision dans leur travail anses en
plus il y à une réunion dans quelques
temps des gens qui sont demandeurs
d'argent au niveau international c'est à
dire que vous avez des gens qui arrive
avec une idée avec l'unité pardon il
faut construire un puits en cause un
parce que dans une région où il ya pas
du tout d'eau c'est très urgent un autre
à une autre urgence et c est là aux voix
un petit peu les demandes et au dispatch
l'argent alors je pense que il ya des
gens parmi nous qui veulent en effet
savoir comment va et dix patients se
dispatcher l'argent et où va-t-il aller
pierre bachelet qu'est ce que vous allez
chanter vous demain et à quelle heure
exactement
moi je passe je passe à 10h36 on va dire
je sais pas si la précision sera autant
de rigueur de même je chante eb je
chante mais je veux d'abord faire
chanter les qu'avec moi donc je vais
chanter les corons je crois que ce sera
le plus simple pour les faire chanter et
puis je fais un duo avec un ami qui
s'appelle marc lavoine et qui a eu très
envie de participer au concert aussi est
en fait une chanson que j'ai que j'ai
écrite avec jean pierre lang qui fait
partie de mon dernier disque s'appelle
quand l'enfant deviendra lé qui je
trouve va assez bien avec notre problème
dernière question est-ce que vous avez
une idée plus précise que d'organiser
des concerts comme c'est comme celui ci
une idée pour aider les pays en détresse
qu'est ce qu'il faudrait faire en france
aujourd'hui mais je crois que vous savez
bon nous à notre niveau à nous on ne
peut pas faire grand chose je crois
qu'on peut faire on peut faire ça on
peut sensibiliser l'opinion on peut
sensibiliser les gouvernements et on
peut recueillir de l'argent maintenant
les autorités je crois que elle elle
peut faire plus c'est à dire qu'il faut
prendre le problème à la base
pourquoi est ce cas de la famine est là
il faut reprendre les problèmes à la
base
essayez de trouver 2 2 oui vos de
l'agriculture au niveau 2 de leur
possibilité à eux de ce qu'on peut le
ramener pour qu'ils puissent après
exploiter leurs propres possibilités
leur propre terrain leur propre
entreprise en pompant industries'
toutefois c'est possible et je crois que
c'est ça qu'il faut verser pas c'est
sûrement pas envoyer de l'argent c'est
c'est temporaire c c'est l'urgence mais
après il faut leur donner l'heure bleue
mois
de s'autogérer et subiste et je pense
que c'est ça mais c'est un métier ça ça
nous faisait pas simple pierre bachelet
merci beaucoup on vous retrouve enfin
pour ceux qui vont à la courneuve demain
à 19 heures 36 et il faut dire que je
concert commence à 10 heures et se
terminent à 20 heures il ya donc 10h02
considérait man avec 60 artistes
français merci beaucoup